évidemment on ne comprend plus comment
ça peut fonctionner à 400 mille cas par
jour ça ne veut pas dire qu'elles sont
mille malades mais quatre cent mille cas
c'est énorme 45 mille élèves enfin bref
en termes de détester tracé isolé ça ne
peut plus fonctionner donc il faut
trouver un autre mode d'opération le
problème c'est que ça fait deux ans que
le virus est là que les enseignants
n'ont pas été dotée en masques ffp2 il
le disait pourtant on a déjà eu le
cirque que le sketch des masques il ya
un an les purificateurs d'air ne sont
pas là on a les ministres qu'il suffit
d'ouvrir les fenêtres mais quand tu fais
de degré zéro degré ouvrir les fenêtres
pour donner cours c'est pas très
confortable voire dangereux donc on
continue à faire comme si on pouvait
bricoler on a des protocoles qui sont
devenus de l'ordre de la folie de la
pensée magique on à jean michel blanquer
air qui dit on ne fait pas grève contre
le virus évidemment que non mais les
gens qui sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
n'ont pas fait grève contre les russes
ils ont fait grève contre ce ministre
est contre ce gouvernement qui commence
à sérieusement cassé les pieds des
français avec des mesures
incompréhensible et inapplicable et
parfaitement hypocrite le gouvernement
le même lui-même le cfa de fait depuis
un mois qu'on sait que ce virus
notamment le variant au micron va
circuler le gouvernement a décidé de le
laisser circuler parce que c'est qu'il
peut pas l'arrêter nations et en même
temps comme il veut dégager sa
responsabilité encore une fois qu'il
veut appliquer ces mêmes méthodes ils
créent ces protocoles qui sont
insupportables pour tout le monde en
faisant croire que ça va arrêter le
virus que l'école reste ouverte en même
temps et qu'il se passera rien mais
quand on voit donc le niveau de virus
qui circule à la fois l'école et fo dans
population française on sait très bien
qu'il a lâché la sphère pas comme tous
les gouvernements d'ailleurs du monde
parce qu'il est impossible pour
l'instant d'arrêter ce virus ce variant
dont heureusement qui a l'air moins
grave que les précédents mais le but
final non dit c'est quand même que tout
le monde la trappe tout le monde est
limité picqué a pas d'autre méthode pour
le faire aujourd'hui